Передові позиції української армії неподалік від Донецька.
До окопів бойовиків самопроголошеної "ДНР" - лічені сотні метрів.
Щоб не стати легкою мішенню для снайпера, пересуватися можна лише зруйнованими
обстрілами будівлями та траншеями. Вони тут - у повний зріст.
У позиційній війні є щось архаїчне. Окопи та бліндажі на Донбасі нагадують укріплення часів Першої світової.
Військові кажуть, що артобстріл може початися будь-якої миті -
міни прилітають хоч і нечасто, але неочікувано. До того ж, прибувши на позицію,
ми чули кілька снайперських пострілів. Тому для запису інтерв'ю солдати просять нас спуститися в бліндаж.
Що Ви думаєте про концентрацію військ Росії на кордонах з Україною?
Якщо брати гіркий досвід 2014-2015 років, то я не думаю, що це просто так.
Не може бути так, щоб зібрати весь резерв російської армії, зігнати його і на Аляску,
і у Воронезьку область, і до Криму, які знаходяться за 30-60 кілометрів від українських кордонів,
щоб просто нагнати для навчань. Не думаю, що це просто так. Хочуть спровокувати нас.
Але, якщо ні, то це чиясь дуже дорога політична гра м'язами,
а розплатяться за неї ті, хто платить податки в Росії.
- А Ви якось готуєтеся до можливого наступу, посилюєте позиції?
Ну, ті позиції, які у нас зараз є, ми їх завжди дообладнуємо, тому що, самі розумієте,
коли живеш у землі, тут постійно щось обвалюється і це такий нескінченний ремонт.
А так - у нас заходи з бойової підготовки проводяться, ми завжди насторожі.
Це - стандартна відповідь українських військових, яку ми чули під час поїздки
вздовж лінії розмежування на Донбасі. Її протяжність - 400 кілометрів.
Крайня південна точка фронту - на Азовському морі. Лише за десять кілометрів від неї
- півмільйонне портове місто Маріуполь. На думку деяких експертів, саме Маріуполь може стати
основною мішенню в разі повномасштабного вторгнення російської армії -
якщо Росія захоче пробити сухопутний коридор до Криму. Загроза для міста існує також з моря.
Виходимо на патрулювання разом з морськими прикордонниками.
У полі зору - корабель берегової охорони ФСБ Росії.
Азовське море, як ви знаєте, це спільне море України і Росії відповідно до угоди.
Разом з тим спостерігається певна така активність кораблів та катерів Російської Федерації.
Як Україна готується до можливої ескалації, про яку зараз всі говорять?
Чи посилюється охорона, оборона?
Я можу сказати одне: ми готові у складі сил Операції об'єднаних сил,
у складі інших підрозділів і військових формувань України. Всі готові і все тримається під контролем.
Тобто ви не посилюєте свої сили?
Звісно, ми постійно тренуємося, готуємося. Можете це розцінювати як посилення.
Але скажу одне: ми готові до будь-яких провокацій.
У 2014-му році Маріуполь став одним з епіцентрів так званої "російської весни" на Донбасі.
Тоді у півмільйонному місті на Азовському морі точилися запеклі бої між сепаратистами
та українськими силовиками.
Про події семирічної давнини в Маріуполі досі нагадують зруйновані будівлі у центрі міста.
Через пів року після звільнення від бойовиків війна повернулися ще раз - на початку 2015 року.
Тоді під час обстрілу міста з реактивної артилерії загинули десятки цивільних.
Від Маріуполя до кордону з Росією - 40 кілометрів.
Утім, попри близькість війни місто живе звичайним життям.
На тлі тривожних повідомлень про скупчення військ Росії на кордонах з Україною
це може здатися дивним.
Самі ж маріупольці кажуть, що за сім років вже звикли до постійної загрози.
Загроза? Та вона не спадала ніколи у нас, ця загроза. Ми були завжди готові.
Так що у нас, слава Богу, як кажуть у козаків, - шашки салом мажемо. Хай приходять.
Вони бачили у Чечні, що таке ад, але ж вони не знають, що таке пекло.
Маріуполь в небезпеці, це так.
А Ви якось готуєтеся до такого сценарію? Є тривожна валіза?
Ні. Я думаю, що в цьому немає сенсу. Ми це вже пережили. Тривожні валізи не допомагають.
Просто тікаєш - і все. Ми навчилися з цим жити.
Загроза є дуже велика. Тому що скупчення таке, яке було у 2014 році. Понад 100 тисяч.
І як би то не було, але для тієї ж Росії це велика купа грошей,
щоб просто показувати свої м'язи.
Але ж що в голові у того карлика - насправді ніхто не може дати точну відповідь.
Тому ми вважаємо, що наше місто повинно бути готове в будь-який момент.
Скільки триває цей конфлікт, ми щороку чуємо одне і те саме: ось, весна почнеться,
почнеться війна - ось з понеділка, ось з нового місяця. Людям просто набридло вже боятися -
намагаються хоч якось себе розвеселити. Неможливо весь час жити в жалобі, жити в страху.
Готуємося до гіршого, але сподіваємося на краще.
А як Ви готуєтеся?
Інструктуємо дітей на випадок ЧП, тривожна валіза завжди під рукою.
Підвал переробили, щоб можна було і зсередини залазити, і зовні - якщо засипле.
Самотужки до можливої ескалації готується і дитячий реабілітаційний центр "Республіка Пілігрим".
У притулку, який облаштувала протестантська "Церква добрих змін",
діти вже знають, що робити у разі бойових дій.
Це на випадок екстреного збору дітей внизу.
У разі, якщо будуть непередбачувані обставини. І війна в тому числі.
У нинішній час, у складній ситуації, яка в нас у Маріуполі, в Україні,
ми цей підвал переобладнали на бомбосховище. У разі необхідності ми зможемо швиденько,
протягом однієї хвилини, спустити сюди дітей і пересидіти якісь складнощі,
якщо навіть будуть бомбити місто.
У нашому місті я бачу написи - "Бомбосховище". Але я навіть не знаю, як ним скористатися.
Це прифронтове місто, а я жодного разу не бачив, щоб навчали населення на випадок екстреної евакуації.
Зараз будь-якого нашого громадянина зупини на вулиці та запитай -
він собі уявляє, як треба евакуюватися? Ніхто не знає. Значить, ми до цього не готові.
Натомість місцева влада запевняє, що плани евакуації та сховища на випадок війни у Маріуполі є.
Щоправда, здебільшого це звичайні підвали. Адже більшість бомбосховищ
були або розпродані, або перебудовані.
Як правило, ми використовуємо підвальні приміщення в житлових багатоповерхових будинках,
ну а приватний сектор відповідно використовує свої вже якісь укриття.
Ця робота ведеться, вона ведеться планомірно, але наших "бойових волонтерів" хвилює те,
що ми не робимо це голосно, що ми не робимо це широко - для того, щоб не сіяти в людей паніку
і для того, щоб ми вселяли у мешканців надію на мирне життя і на розвиток наших територій.
Багато хто стурбований, кажуть: "Ми не знаємо, чи є сховище і де?"
Я не знаю маршруту руху трамвая, але я в місто доїжджаю.
Тому люди говорять, так: "Я не знаю". Але насправді всі внутрішньо розуміють,
де у них знаходиться підвал.
Тим часом у дитячому притулку "Пілігрим" самотужки готуються до найгіршого сценарію.
У те, що влада зможе професійно організувати евакуацію, тут не вірять.
Навіть запаслися пальним. Адже добре пам'ятають 2014 рік,
коли вивозили дітей з міста власним транспортом.
Я бачив 14-й рік, я бачив 15-й рік. Це нічому нашу країну не вчить.
Всі думають: "А раптом пронесе". Знаєте, як у нас починають посипати дороги,
коли в грудні місяці пішов сніг: "Ой, несподівано пішов сніг". Хоча зима почалася ще раніше.
Та людина, яка приготувалася, більш захищена. Будь-яке загострення в місті -
в першу чергу закриваються заправки, потім зникає світло, пропадає зв'язок.
І тому треба все мати своє для евакуації - для того, щоб зберегти життя дітей і наших співробітників.
Попри величезні блок-пости на в'їзді і виїзді з міста, об'їхати їх полями
та уникнути перевірки на восьмому році війни - не проблема.
Ми об'їжджаємо блок-пост, так? - Так.
Ти ж бачиш, зараз ми поїдемо по іншій дорозі. Я так думаю, якщо така дорога є -
значить, хтось об'їжджає, і, виходить, це комусь потрібно. А якщо це комусь потрібно, то я ставлю собі питання:
"Кому це потрібно - проїхати непоміченим через блок-пост?"
Ви вважаєте, це недбалість, що повз блок-пости можна проїхати?
- Для мене це взагалі смішно - як в країні, яка восьмий рік воює, може бути слово "недбалість"?
Це злочин - будемо так говорити.
Між Маріуполем та лінією фронту - загородження та протитанковий рів.
Гільза. Тут були бої, стріляли. Тут була перша лінія оборони.
Зараз це наша територія, а колись "нуль" був у Маріуполі. І це все була сіра зона. Тут були бої.
У 14-му році було прокопано чотириметровий рів, щоб танки не пройшли.
Якщо у 14-му році боялися, що буде наступ на Маріуполь і викопали цей рів,
то зараз, під час ескалації ситуації, ніхто навіть не готується, не поправили цей рів.
Виходить, ніхто ні про що не думає, всім абсолютно все одно.
Ось чому я кажу, що керівництво міста, нашої країни, ООС абсолютно нічого не думає про Маріуполь,
про захист Маріуполя і його громадян.
Проїхавши кількасот кілометрів уздовж лінії розмежування,
наша знімальна група не помітила посиленої військової активності не лише у Маріуполі,
але й в інших прифронтових містах.
Схоже, військові та цивільні на Донбасі звикли до війни та значно менше переймаються
через скупчення російських військ на кордонах, ніж політики у Києві та на Заході.